she's here tonight
you might want to grab the tissues
because adele's former teacher just
surprised her on stage and the whole
thing may have you crying harder than
when you first heard adele's new album
30. it's been a complete whirlwind but
it's like so much fun as well during the
33 year old grammy winners itv concert
special an audience with adele in london
emma thompson asked the star if there
was anyone specific who had inspired her
when she was young and adele opened up
about a teacher who had a big impact on
her yeah i had a teacher at chestnut
grove who taught me english that was
miss mcdonald she got me really into
literature a lot i've always been
obsessed with english and obviously now
at lyrics but she also did street dance
she was so bloody cool
so
engaging and like she really made us
care and we knew that she cared about
us and stuff like that and it was just
she said well with gold bracelets old
and gold like sick rings i don't know
she was bloody cool yeah and so
relatable and likeable that i really
look forward to my english lessons yeah
you know what's coming
emma revealed that miss mcdonald was
actually there in the audience and when
the two met on stage it was pure
waterworks
[Applause]
[Music]
i told you you'd need the tissues
anyway the two who hadn't seen each
other since adele was about 12 years old
had a sweet little ketchup before adele
joked that she had cried so hard she
needed to get her makeup redone are you
still teaching no no no
i'm just looking after my family
[Music]
sorry
don't cry thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
pretty sweet right well it gets even
sweeter oh my god well i can't get your
number from them or something so yeah of
course of course
yeah all right i've got my makeup fix
adele shared the moment on twitter
calling her return to london quote
heaven of course the powerhouse singer
dropped her fourth studio album 30 last
week her first since 2015's 25. and
since adele officially announced the
album last month she's been candid about
how her new music was largely inspired
by her split from simon kannecki the two
finalized their divorce in march what's
my next album to be based on
divorce babe divorce and during her sit
down with zayn low for apple music she
said she can't even listen to her song
to be loved without shedding a few tears
i'll be the one
to catch myself this time
i don't think i'll do it live no too
much well i can't i can't even listen to
it
so no
what happens when you listen to it if
you were to i know i have to leave the
room i have to leave it i get really
upset get really choked up as for her
track my little love adele says she
wrote it with their nine-year-old son
angelo in mind specifically his
experience with the breakup it was clear
that he was feeling it even though i
thought i was doing a very good job of
being like everything's fine you know
but i also knew i wasn't being as
present you know you know i was present
like in real life but like i just wasn't
really there and he plucked up the
courage just to very articulately say to
me you're basically a ghost like you
might as well not be here for him you
know to be little and say i can't see
you to my face broke my heart and adele
fought back tears recalling the kindness
that her little one showed her it's a
lot for him like you know and
i just feel like him sticking with me
not asking to not stay at my house not
asking to not spend time with me still
always saying
is that all going to see my mum now like
you know and stuff like that meant that
he was being my friend and he had some
empathy for me